vous savez que les gens vous aiment le
plus en plus demandeurs de plus les
fusées vous êtes bientôt dans le top 50
des français préféré des français vous
le savez ça je suis pas je le capital
sympathie non mais vous êtes énorme
capital sympathie et je vous dis qu'on
fasse une interview qui vous montre sur
votre meilleur jour vas-y je suis pour
je me suis réveillée alors j'ai dit tu
t'es réveillé pour ça donc allons-y la
dernière fleur bleue
joey starr interview fleur bleue est ce
que vous croyez au coup de foudre jo et
huawei est ce que vous étiez timide la
première fois on met toujours en jeu
sont elle s'appelait comment la première
dans ce n'est pas tout de suite
ouais est ce que vous avez est ce que
vous l'avez écrit un poème au moins
j'aurai n'ont même pas non pour
regretter est ce que vous ferez des
conseils à votre meilleure amie en cas
de peine de coeur c'est pas comme ça que
c'est comme ça que ça se passe on
normalement oui mon ordre déclare bien
sûr landreau fin j'en parle mais rey au
conseil ne me demandez pas conseil est
ce que vous aimez effeuiller les
marguerites je t'aime beaucoup
passionnément à la folie pas du tout
c'est moi qui ai marqué vélo là
à durer vous faites quoi pour la saint
valentin
je vous envoie des fleurs à ma mère à
votre mère c'est tout bon à quelqu'un
d'autre sites web à valberg
principalement d'accord vous offrez des
roses rouges n'ont pas votre mère ouais
amoureux de ma mère donc ouais hein ils
vous ont repensé par magie ça vous
dirait j'aurai des violences sur votre
prochain disque
c'est quoi la question c'est vrai que tu
penses à faire une reprise et petit
bonhomme en mousse
hélas
c'est un peu la chance
oui